what do you get when you bring more than
100 of the most famous and magnificent
collector cards to the entertainment
capital of the world you get las vegas
concur delegates to benefit miracle
flights did i say it right perfect
joining me to tell us more is the
founder and ceo of las vegas concourse
stuart sobek and kathy roller from
miracle flights welcome you two thank
you so much for being a part of this
incredible event stuart tell us a little
bit about las vegas concourse what is it
exactly so it is the super bowl of car
shows of car events it's a competition
where cars come from all over the world
and they're judged in an event they go
head to head for the grand prize what
are what are they being judged on
exactly they're judged on beauty style
grace
restoration just general condition but
they're the some of the best most
beautiful cars in the world what are
some of your favorites that you've seen
well they're all my favorite
but they're all different things there's
something different for everybody
there's so many different cars there so
you're bringing these incredible cars
and you are going to be
putting them out for public the public
to see
where where else would you get to see
cars like this but this amazing event
for miracle flights so can you tell me a
little bit about what's going to be
happening yeah so it's like a pop-up
museum okay these cars come from all
over the world for a one-day event and
they're here this is the only time
you'll see them all in person and
they're judged and of course we're doing
it to help our friends at miracle
flights let's talk to you about miracle
flights kathy such a fan and you guys do
amazing work one of your ambassadors
levi is one of my absolute favorites we
love little levi tell everybody about
what miracle flights does sure so
miracle flights is a national charity
based right here in las vegas and we
provide free flights for children that
have to travel for medical needs and
even through the pandemic we've been
flying so still about 700 flights every
month wow so even through the pandemic
and this is at no cost to the family
right cost right how is it that you are
able to provide
so many opportunities for these kids to
get that medical help well through
amazing partners like stewart and
concourse different community events and
partnerships that help tie us into their
events and
share their network with us at our
mission
so we're so grateful thank you
tell us a little bit about the kids and
how they react when they get to
experience this so
you're gonna you know levi so levi will
be there we also have maddie who's
another ambassador and both of these
kiddos are gonna have their fancy wheels
uh their wheelchairs uh at
the event and they're just going to
be the light of this event and help
just share the mission and also just
bring it to forefront that concourse is
such a community supporter and
specifically to this non-profit now now
you said it best stuart there's it's
kind of like a dual event you've got a
pre-game like a a tailgating party and
then you've got the main event tell us a
little bit about uh both of them yeah so
the opening party is on thursday from 3
30 to 6 30 at the shelby museum shelby
heritage center right here in town
and it's just an event it's a free event
for car clubs for people to come out
kind of see what we do learn about us
and get excited for the big show which
is on saturday from noon to six at the
las vegas ballpark and where do people
get tickets if they want to check it out
and help out miracle flights the tickets
are available ticketmaster ticketmaster
you can get them help a great cause and
i'm telling you you're not going to see
cars like this anywhere this is a great
opportunity so check it out there's the
there's the pre-game event conquerors
davant uh that it all kicks off on
october 21st through the 24th you can
get more information at las vegas
concourse dot
or call 702-992-0512
over to you jillian